[Music]
thank you all so much for joining us
today happy Thursday nice to see
everybody at the data science hangout if
this is your first time here today so
nice to meet you but thank you all for
spending the Thursday with us if we
haven't met yet I'm Rachel dumpy I host
the hang out and Lead customer marketing
at posit this is our open space to chat
about data Science Leadership questions
you're facing and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data across
different
Industries and so we're here every
Thursday at the same time same place uh
except the week after next we'll be at
the posit conference in Chicago so we
won't have a hangout that week but I'm
excited to get to meet so many of you
there in person um but anyways if you're
watching this recording at some point in
the future on YouTube and you are
thinking I want to join them live you
can use the link below and the details
uh to add it to your calendar too but at
the hangout we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everybody and we love to hear from
everyone no matter your years of
experience titles industry or languages
that you work into and every week I'm
joined by a different leader from the
community who joins to share their
experience and answer questions from you
all so it is totally okay if you want to
just listen in here maybe you're on your
lunch break or you're kind of having to
multitask but there's always three ways
you can jump in and ask questions to or
provide your own perspective so you can
raise your hand on zoom and I'll keep an
eye out you can put questions in the
zoom chat and feel free to just put a
little star next to it if it's something
you want me to read instead um and then
we also have a slido link where you can
ask questions
anonymously uh and Caitlyn if you don't
mind sharing that in the chat right now
that oh Hannah got it already awesome
thank you um but you can ask questions
anonymously there as well um but with
all that thanks again so much for
joining us I am so excited to be joined
by my co-host today Colonel Chris
sailing director of innovation at US
Army Human Resources command and Chrissa
I'd love to kick things off with maybe
having you introduce yourself and
sharing a little bit about your role
today and something you like to do
outside of work too no that sounds good
thank you so much for that Rachel um so
as you said I'm the director of
innovation for US Army Human Resources
command and everybody always tries to
figure out what that is like innovation
has become a buzzword we always talk
about Innovation theater and everything
else our job is to be a little bit of a
future concept cell for the Commanding
General so that we can be a little bit
more removed from the daily asss and
tasks and figure out how we're going to
take an update and sometimes transform
our processes to get after those future
Concepts so I have a team that is
predominantly technologist I have a lot
of data scientists I have a cyber guy
have a networks guy I have a human
resources digital transformation subject
matter expert and a recruiting team and
that's just the start of us we're a year
old and I think we're going to expand by
another 10 positions or so this coming
year that's great thank you and outside
of work what's something you like to do
I I like to cook so to me that's my zen
I'll put on some music and I'll go in
the kitchen and cook something nice so I
know you said this as a new team here
can you share a little bit about how the
creation of that team came to be and
maybe how you work with some other
departments across the Army too yeah no
it really kind of started when I was
working in um I just for some context
I've been working out of the army people
space for seven going on eight years now
which is kind of atypical but a lot of
what we've been doing is digital
modernization and
transformation um the Army came out with
the army people strategy I want to say
in 2019 or early 2020 that talked about
how we wanted to modernize how we did
talent management pushed a lot did a lot
of different pilots and prototypes got a
bunch of policies changed we did some
great stuff there and then realized that
we hadn't modernized the mechanisms to
actually get us to Talent manage
we were still basically assigning people
and moving people around using the same
old systems and a lot of them really
needed to be updated so we needed a way
to look out and see how we could do that
cohesively rather than just looking at
the individual processes the
directorates so General Drew made the
decision that he was going to establish
the Innovation cell to solidify our HRC
2030 Vision that we have um and to look
at how we're going to step forward in
our technology and our business
practices to achieve it I see um
Katherine you had a question in the chat
do you want to jump in here first um it
was really just a question on whether or
not all of the people on your team are
in the active duty in the military or if
some of those are also GS positions or
what your team makeup looks like yeah
it's military and civilian right now
we're mostly military just because I
took my team I realigned my team that I
had for talent management with me but
we've made a couple civilian hires and
we're going to make a number of other um
civilian hires um so a question I had
wanted to ask you about
is Kaitlyn and I were talking about how
you've managed to kind of break silos
between the different Army departments
and getting people to work together to
help achieve the the team's Vision um
and I was just wondering like how have
you been able to do that and what tips
do you have for some of us who are maybe
trying to do the same thing and break
silos within our own
organizations yeah I mean one of the
biggest skills that we we harp a lot on
command in the military but that's not
the most important leadership skill one
of the most important things that we
consider is building coalitions you know
how do you reach out to your
counterparts and get a whole bunch of
people crashing together on a common
goal or a common understanding I think
one of the places we've had the biggest
success with that is with our data
literacy program we had a lot of people
with needs we had a lot of people who
are looking for more data
and we were able to pull people from
throughout the Army to look at this as a
project and get it scaled up so now it's
part of a professional military
education thank you I I think Mike's
question there kind of touches on this
as well Mike do you want to expand on
that yeah and actually I think you
answered part of it but um you know
you're you're as you're building your
team and this is a kind of question that
we hear a lot at data science hang out
did those team members already have data
science skills or are they having to
learn as they go so I had a mix um one I
hired straight out of grad school out of
the Georgetown data science program
another I hired from Notre Dame um the
computer science program so they had a
number of different data skills they had
to you know kind of cross train into
other areas of emphasis um obviously
natural language processing and
texturing analysis is Big when you're in
the people space um one of them came in
with a lot of those skills the others
are having to learn it and then I have a
couple other folks who were very good
statistical analysts didn't um have the
same kind of experience in building out
some of the applications we were
building so we're using a number of
different kind of training programs
upscaling part pair coding to try to get
them set on that then I do have some
folks who come in straight from the HR
side very um limited exposure to data
and data science and it gave me an
opportunity to kind of test our data
literacy training on them to get them to
ask more you know intelligent data
questions not that they weren't asking
intelligent questions but there's less
translation needed between them and our
our data folks I'm sure I'll follow up
questions in a minute but I'll come
back Patrick I see you just put a
question in the chat want to jump in
here yeah thank you Rachel it's sort of
a follow up to what you just said
Kristen thank you for being here I'm
fascinated by this uh you mentioned uh
text analysis and NLP what are your key
data sources uh for for bringing that in
uh to the analytic Pipeline and then
also uh other data sources more more
quantitatively Focus stuff
so we use we we use a number of
different um kind of commercial products
we use hugging Cas we use a number of
other things you guys are probably
familiar with to help us um at least
kind of break down our taxonomies but
most of the work that we're doing comes
from our evaluation entry system where
we are looking at evaluations we're
looking at Duty descriptions we're
looking at how we um establish our
taxonomies and ontologies for uh job
competencies um there are a lot of
libraries out there that we could bu but
there's not really a Spacey Library out
there for um military competency so
we've had to build practically build our
own does that kind of answer your
question yeah my answer is all over the
place no that that's awesome and uh it's
it's wonderful work youall are doing so
thank you very much oh thank you and I
go back to the conversation about like
breaking down silos a bit um Luke had
asked in the the chat in such a gigantic
operation how have you been able to
actually break down those data silos to
get what you need so the first step we
had to do was convince senior leaders to
be directive I mean it's it's horrible
to say you think we're gonna want to
cooperate and share but nobody wants to
cooperate and share their data um so we
went to secretary of the army and said I
have a directive here that says all the
people in the people space will share
their people data period so it was our
first people analytics um core directive
we've refreshed that a couple times and
we've identified our person event data
environment as kind of being the
semiofficial repository for that data
sharing we get a lot of people who are
working in that environment it's it's um
probably something a lot of you will be
familiar with it's just a massive data
warehouse with a virtual machine
environment on top of it that we use to
drop um different data sets into do
different projects but yeah now we had
to basically order everybody to share
their data I'm trying to think how that
might Translate to some of these teams
here too yeah well it's like I mean I
think the biggest piece we talked about
building coalitions you know there's
going to be we tried to do some data
Summits across the Army just to bring
people together and talk about what they
were working on and man it would be
really cool if we could just get our
hands on well there's probably somebody
in the room who knows how to get their
hands on that data so we started this
little bit of a coalition talking about
wouldn't it be great if we could do all
this and that's how we pitch the
argument to leadership to say look we've
got to
we've got to get here we've got to be
able to do this and we need your support
and endorsement ours was very directive
but I think if you have a leader there
who who does give you that champion that
support and endorsement that might be a
good a corollary
definitely um Colter I see you had a
question in the chat want to jump in
here next sure yeah and you actually
just kind of answered it but I was
wondering if if from your perspective if
if you've seen similar data
modernization efforts happening uh
either within other commands I'm
thinking of like uh Futures command or
even within kind of individual branches
within the Army if if there are similar
efforts going on oh yeah no we've really
got a just it warms my heart data
modernization Trend
um army Futures command is a big partner
their data science division Nate Parker
over there is a big partner of ours in
looking at how we can get more agile
data science I mean I hate to say agile
not in terms of Agile development but
something that'll Flex better into um
our different
requirements um so we're working with
him and seeing if we can use that
instead of our current environment we've
reached out to 18th Airborne Corps who
is using our Vantage program which is
built on paler Foundry uh to do a lot of
their work a lot of um their data work
informing
decisions we've worked with the Army AI
integration center that is now up at
Carnegie melon we've got a lot of great
Partners in the West Point I can't leave
out West Point um partner and good
friend Colonel Nick Clark who started
our data literacy uh training program
that we've kind of Incorporated and
taken Army wide um but yeah and I think
kind of coming back to finding those
Partners in the Coalition as as we
figured out who all is working in this
space we've been able to kind of give
each other a hand up when we need when
people need resources or endorsement and
it's really made things spread faster I
know we we touched on the data literacy
program a few times and I I was just
curious ious like what does that program
look like so the initial iteration was
just 10 hours of course work basically
making people better critical consumers
of data um oh hey Nate's here yes you
always got your shout out um making
people better critical consumers of data
that's expanded to about a 16-hour
course that's going to be in kind of our
basic um professional military education
there's a second level that they're
going to get in that next iteration
which is more Hands-On using the common
tools that you have available we'll
start on we'll start folks out you know
just doing basic statistical analysis in
Excel or whatever they have access to
want to start introducing them into RN
python so that you know it's not scary
we can learn how to code we share some
of those resources so if they're
interested or if they branches
opportunities they go into level three
which is where we take them into some
some in-depth analytic training that
walks them through our data competency
model and we basically create learning
paths for all the different things that
they want to do if they want to get into
different types of coding if they want
to do more NLP I need more NLP
programmers
um yeah that's always the fun part too
when you talk about NLP with a bunch of
of data scientists you know who your
natural language program processors are
and then you know who your optimizers
are because they're wait what are you
talking about not your programs
for that that actually leads me to a a
question that was asked anonymously was
um how much is r or python used in your
organization so a majority of our folks
are python users just because of um our
Vantage program being built on Foundry
which is you know P pice Park um I've
got a couple of folks who do use our
fairly regularly um doing their analysis
we had a lot of people on kind of the
more Legacy programs looking at SPSS SAS
not to disparage those with they're
expensive so we want people getting on
things where they can more rapidly
develop and share like my team we try to
use as much of the existing language and
share code as much as possible but it it
gets difficult I think somebody um I see
Marlene's comment um I I think BEC
somebody brought it up earlier the
sensitive nature of the data that we're
working with I mean most of our
Personnel data is unclassified but it
might as well be um SEI secure um
compartmentalized information just
because you have the um the Personnel
trying to remember what pii stands for
um you have that component of it you
have medical data you have hippo
protections you have legal protections
all these different kind of caveats that
go around any kind of a soldier data
object you create so we want people
being able to use the tools yes
personally identifiable information
thank you guys I just had a I had I had
to go look it up too because you say I
say pii so frequently I forget what the
acronym is yeah now we speak acronym
it's like we know what I mean I just
know what it stands
for um it's funny as we're as we're
covering some of these questions we get
to a few of the others that are asked in
the chat here but I know on this topic
of pii CA you had a question in the chat
on highly protected data do you want to
I expand on that with your question sure
uh a thanks G for answering some of that
already but um I guess uh even talking
about breaking through these different
groups um so different departments I'm
sure have different uh things that they
consider are protected or secure so how
did you kind of deal with that challenge
of trying to be like um these are the
kind of tools we've built to ensure
security of data within different
departments and you know to assure that
this is not just all going to be shared
across every team or every group and was
that challenging for you so we really um
we really spent a lot of time working on
our data governance our policies and our
protections and we spent a lot of time
building that out the person event data
environment um it's a secure environment
you can't download anything you can't
take anything out of the environment uh
people get fussy about that because it
makes it me it's hard to access and
you've got a request access through a
project to certain things um but that at
least you know when people are realizing
that you know nobody's going to um
nobody's going to pull everything into a
CS v file or spreadsheet that's going to
be sitting on their desktop that
provides a certain amount of comfort we
also just kind of restricted the access
to um any kind of identifiable
information for a lot of projects unless
it's specifically needed so a lot of the
work there can actually be done with
deidentified information and we're
trying to add more information back into
into circulation now get people more
access now that we've kind of done the
lockdown um but still it's it's always a
little bit of a a thing we watch there
are so many great questions piling in
here um Marlene I see you had a question
in the chat do you want to jump in here
oh sure um hi Chris thanks for joining
us today I know I'm so sorry guys that
is a over beers whoever's going to um
posit com we'll talk about my Hiatus but
I've missed you all dearly even if we've
met like for two seconds on these chats
just know that you guys were are nral
part of my week so um please take a
little hug for yourself in that anyway
so Chris I digress um
I I'm just kind of interested in you
know what's like a soft skill that
you've started to really appreciate from
your team here because we always talk a
lot about the technical aspect right and
the the skills that that are attributed
to being a good programmer and or data
scientist but I think there's so much
that has to be kind of focused on about
what AIDS in all of that stuff right um
so yeah what's a what's a soft scale
that maybe you've kind of learned to
appreciate more and more with your team
so a lot of it kind of Unearthed itself
when we were doing our data lit and it's
teaching I mean we have to have people
who have the soft skills that support
being able to teach you know it's like
how can you connect with somebody how
can you kind of empathize with them
enough to be able to see where they're
coming from with their question how do
you put the process that you're trying
to describe or the result you're trying
to describe in A Accessible context kind
of do those understanding checks I mean
it sounds very soft in this context but
it's a critical piece of being able to
translate our solutions to a decision
maker who
you know if a decision maker can't
really use our data or our decisions or
understand it it's a tree that fell in
the woods so we've really kind of
emphasized that teaching
ability yeah and I think something
magical happens I mean especially for
the rubber ducky programmers right when
you're explaining a problem to somebody
else I think some magic yeah thanks Li
you know some magic happens there um
even for our understanding and or um our
development of aha moments so anyway
thanks for that that Chim me in I'll
pass B on good to see you again Rachel
thanks yeah thank thank you all for
joining so nice to see everybody here I
um I scrolling up through some of the
questions and thank you so much to the
posit team in the background helping me
gather everything um but Ralph I see you
asked a question a bit earlier do you
want to jump in here yeah thank you uh
morning uh so Ralph Asher I'm a marine
and just thinking about you know my
experience in entry-level training both
as a uh both as a student and as an
instructor in that and it was very
industrial and it was one siiz fits-all
and I was curious if anything that your
team's doing is informing that and even
maybe uh before that in the recruiting
environment thank you oh goodness I
could speak on that a lot I would love
to dig into how we structure our
professional military education so that
it's not the one-size fits-all um we're
thinking the way we're rolling out the
different data competencies I think is
going to help a little bit with that
because one of the things we wanted to
do was have all kinds of different
levels all kinds of different learning
paths figure out how to make this
accessible and how to make this apply to
people's you know what what were they
going to use the most then we kind of
frontload that to give them the
confidence and confidence they need um
sometimes I mean that's just the
conceptual piece of how to ask a good
data question and we W and we workshop
with people through what that looks like
there's a lot of data storytelling and
how to read you know graphs how to read
statistics how to be um a good critical
consumer of all of the things that we
see the news um then we start getting
into of some of the the more Hands-On
skills but you know kind of at your
question in terms of your question
that's something I would like to go
after I think um our combined arm Center
Commander General beagle is going after
that but it's it's a work of progress I
see Allan you had a question um about
the different teams working together and
we' love to have you ask that next yeah
sure um thanks Rachel hi Chris I'm
curious um in my experience it's it's
hard sometimes to be able to like sort
of celebrate achievements or Innovative
things that like folks on my team do
because their sensitivity about how much
we can share sometimes even internally
but for sure externally with like the
broader world of data engineering and
and data science and I imagine that's
really acute for for you but I don't
know if that's the right assumption I'm
curious if you've got ways to sort of
manage that and and deal with that sort
of dilemma of how do you help your team
feel like they belong to a community but
keep the right you know borders between
like you know oversharing and and
keeping the right level of discretion
and sensitivity and
stuff yeah no that is an excellent
question because one of the things that
I've had to do over the past um two
three four years is be the Army
spokesperson for people analytics and
how we're using data how we're
modernizing promotions how we're doing
all this stuff a lot of that is
extremely sensitive and it's hard being
able to talk about what we're doing
especially to an expert audience
when we can't go into the nuts and bolts
of how we built out the particular
program we've really tried to you know
put together the nuts and bolts uh in
terms of competencies you know we can
talk all day about how we use Tex string
analysis to automate the initial
screening for command selection now
don't necessarily tell you the rubric
that we're using to judge these things
because we don't want that to
necessarily get out that's kind of a
rough example but we we do try to be
transparent and part of being
transparent with the about what they're
doing what we're doing with their data
especially when it's their personal data
is important I don't know if that's a h
more of a non- answer but uh I kind of
tapped answer on it we try to talk about
as much as we can yeah it's I think it's
um uh it's interesting to know that that
like you've got the same dilemma um and
I think I saw Mark pop up the note like
that kind of question probably holds for
lots of HR analytics stuff like broadly
and it applies for us in areas like R&D
and how we solve manufacturing problems
and like that well It's tricky to figure
out that right balance so I appreciate
it thanks yeah no no worries we do try
to um kind of come up with mockup
versions of some of the algorithms we
use that we can put publicly on git so
like there is a publicly accessible
version of the retention prediction
model we use just the base um interval
forecasting engine out on git so the
more I think we can develop those then
we also have multi-purpose models and we
can get the community to critique how we
put it together in the
methodology cool neat thank
you I imagine that link to uh that that
git example is going to be something
people are interested in yeah as soon as
I can I'll shoot it over to you you can
share it with the group yeah I can put
it up with the recording too awesome
Katherine I I know you had a question
that kind of touched on what Allan said
but I just wanted to make sure to see if
you wanted to expand on that a bit or if
that answered your question too uh my
question kind of centers around on the
fact that this is not a problem unique
to the Army or any you know any industry
in general but is there some sort of
higher level like cross Branch
Innovation for HR people leaders that
that maybe your team is a part of or do
you share any of that with the Air Force
the Navy any of those other kinds of
military organizations that you might
have access to yeah so we um we reach
out to aworks and softworks uh a lot of
their innovation is not
necessarily in how they're building they
do build a lot of prototypes the same
way we do for different tools we're
trying to roll out um but a lot in the
Contracting space we've had to pull in
expertise in that we've talked with the
Navy director of military personnel
management he's very interested in
sharing some of the things that they've
done for my Navy HR with us and getting
a readout on what we've been doing for
automating and updating our promotions
and performance um
we have a lot of and I think this is
probably common everywhere we have a lot
of these little networks built um but
it's very unofficial I don't think you
could make a official Innovation Network
although we are tied in with defense
Innovation unit the national security
innovation Network for some of the
things that we're working on but the
rest of it is just kind of point to
point it's a small space for working in
at least in the dod side and the in the
Army side um it's a small enough space
that we work in that we kind of know
who's working in it and if we don't know
somebody personally who's working on a
particular problem someone in that
network does so we've been lucky thank
you I see there there was an anonymous
question um that said apart from the NLP
that you shared what are some other
typical analysis that you do oops L you
for just a second can you repeat the
last part of that question sorry it the
question was apart from the NLP example
what are some other typical analysis
that you do
well one of the programs that we're
working on is a um it's just a big
neural net that takes in all our our
Personnel data and rolls out a
prediction a prediction Vector of How
likely someone is to ATT trip from
service over time um so that's we do a
lot of retention analysis we do
um we're trying to figure out how to
improve on an existing simulation that
shows how our distribution could get
backed up um we want to try to for cast
what our um our force is going to look
like our Force inventory is going to
look like over five years because
obviously you know probably heard in the
news about the recruiting issues um issu
sounds too kind but I'm on camera so
I'll just say recruiting issues but
that's going to leave a little bit of a
trough in the force even if we cover uh
we recover from it in the very near
future it's still going to be something
that we have to build our inventory
around over the next you know five 10
years so we want to be able to take a
look at what that looks like and
prioritize skill development and
assignments accordingly so we're trying
to build some of those forecasting
models then um we're trying to work with
a number of different elements working
with the Army software Factory on just
getting data shared into applications
that'll make it easier for folks to do
things like finding Child Care PCS Etc
permanent change of station I don't want
to speak in
acronym
thank you very
much um let's see I'm feel like I'm
firing questions away at you we have so
many great questions um let's see no
there're hasing some great stuff this is
fun one other oh let's let's jump jump
over to your question deep sha do you
want to jump in
here sure um thanks Rachel thanks Chris
um I think a lot of it you've already
answered but are there as you started to
build your team are there success
stories that you were able to share with
um your leadership or other teams that
you're trying to get data from to say
like look what we're capable of if you
cooperated uh to get that momentum and
buy and
going yeah that was one of the biggest
things we had to do initially was to
show show value I mean we wanted to turn
on find projects that were kind of quick
wins that we could say hey look how much
easier this is to answer with data
and trying to make that case business
case to leaders um one of the things
that we used I worked for about two
years on a structure to a Personnel um
mismatch program because we were trying
to figure out you know with all the
rapid changes for Army structure you
know why why did we have a force that
looked very different from the structure
that we required and the answer was you
know obviously the senior leaders can
say I want to build this type of
organization the requirements are built
and it takes much longer for the supply
to catch up so as an argument for
datadriven talent management where we
look at attribute-based assignment
versus you know branch and a grade like
look how much we can reduce the Gap in
what we have versus what we assigned
because we have these skills here
they're just coded under another um
another specialty if we make some of
these positions more IMM material then
we have a lot more assignment options
and the ability to fill that Talent
requirement so that one was was fairly
easy we did it with existing data
existing position analysis we have much
more in-depth understanding the
requirements now um but we were able to
show very quickly it's like okay all of
these stationing issues that we think
thought initially were a problem much
less of a problem it's a great example
thank you grais thank you yeah thank you
and I um Echo aran's comment love the
idea of quick wins projects and kind of
spending some time thinking about what
they could those could be in our own
organizations too um Brad I see you have
your hand ra here do you want to jump in
sure uh a lot of lot of focus is is is
being paid to Ai and machine learning
and data mesh and data Fabric and those
are I feel like ADV advanced
concepts XYZ in the alphabet and if you
don't do the ABCs the xyz's aren't going
to turn out very well uh do you guys
currently have a a platform around
either data catalog or governance that
that helps people find the right data at
the right time and the right reason and
and and use it appropriately so we're
that we've rolled one out doesn't have
the kind of use that I would like it to
have it's the Enterprise um edsc
Enterprise data uh Enterprise data
system catalog so it should have
everything registered in it that we have
and we're collecting and if we could get
more people accessing it I think that
would go toward a lot of our problems
the hard part is we're not using the
tool directly in with the data systems
where that data is stored so we have to
manually update it but it it's something
that we've considered we've identified
that as a need
and having it one of the things I'm
looking for is a more intelligent data
catalog that we could roll out I think
this question kind of touches upon this
as well that George asked what systems
are using to share data with people is
that a different use than what we're
talking about now so a lot of it is you
know point-to-point transfer we do just
you know extract transfer load and we've
got a number of our systems talking to
each other through apis but otherwise we
just have to figure out kinds of
different ways to get um the data sent
to the data science environment that
we're
using it's not always easy I mean we
were at the point where they were
emailing or they're not emailing but
where they were physically mailing hard
drives and we're trying to get away from
that obviously
yeah um an anonymous question
interesting question on slido is how
does your team build their own
professional portfolios for when they
may move on to a new job is how can they
show what they've done without sharing
protected
info yeah we've we've talked about that
a lot and um the way I've kind of
treated the work my team does and
because I've been in the position I've
been in even though this is a new team a
lot of the team I'm working with was one
I did worked with with three and a half
years in Army talent management with
army people analytics and then a couple
years prior to that in G1 I treat all my
new hires like
um like their grad students coming in
and they're going to come they're going
to explore the data they're going to get
familiar with the data sets we use get
familiar with the business processes and
then they kind of will find something
that works as a thesis project so like
what what is the thing that grabs them
what is the thing that's most
interesting what's most suited to their
capabilities and we've really kind of
built things around that um we've been
lucky in that there's been so much to do
that we could um align people to the
projects that they are most interested
in the thing that we're trying to work
out is you know what happens if we have
projects that are prioritized that don't
have the same grab um but that that's
kind of how I have it I have this whole
laundry list of things that I want to
get after and I kind of like you know
your grad adviser did with their
research projects and like hey Leta
point you in this direction go research
this a little bit develop this program
or this problem a little bit more let's
see if that grabs you yeah that's an
interesting idea like the thesis project
for for new people coming in and I see
there's a conversation kind of happening
in the chat as well about um like well
adding on to that idea of quick wins and
then Alan I I saw you mentioned
something about how you do onboarding
where people can contribute right away
would you want to jump in here and share
that sure um I don't think I don't know
if I have a ton to add we we just um
really try conscientiously to think
about as someone's coming onto the team
or someone's joining the organization
how do we set them up so that they have
something meaningful to contribute as
soon as possible so they don't feel like
they're waiting to like become credible
for a year before people feel like they
can contribute and so it's just really
important to give people ways to feel
successful um soon um and and Chris I
was also reacting to that sort of
incoming grad student kind of approach I
think that's such an interesting model
to to set that up to say like explore
this find something interesting dig into
it we'll see if we can make a project
out of it um it's really cool and I also
appreciate the Dilemma of like okay we
have to prioritize that against the the
portfolio as
well no I like the idea of incorporating
the quick wins too because that's
basically the kind of stuff we have that
new people could get after like this is
this one is I hate using the term low
hanging fruit but this one's kind of
primed ready to go jump on this chew on
it use it to get familiar with the data
and then we kind of go and develop from
there okay I might need help with this
acronym maybe uh a slido question is how
have you navigated OPM requirements as
you seek to modernize Recruitment and
retainment retainment
strategies yeah office of personnel
management so we really just had to get
into the same way we did the military
side the letter of the law it's like
what what are these things actually say
that we must do and what is written in
DOD or Army policy or something that's
just more of like a legacy like we
really try to go back to some of these
things and talk about ground what the
ground truth is um we have really had
much of an issue modernizing at least on
the data side because of all the direct
hire authorities that we have um we've
really tried to push also towards um
doing more with term hires which scares
people in government they're like Oh you
mean they're not going to make this a
career it's like people are working in
the space don't want to spay spend their
lifetime in the same job anyway you know
they're going to come in they're going
to do a thing they're going to pick a
next thing and you can see if that piece
is um
you know that particular position is
validated at the same level because the
Project's mature you might need some
entry level folks or you might need some
folks to do data development data
cleaning and then after that you'll
realize You' got a different use for
that data different project the
composition of your project team is
going to change so we've really tried to
use the most flexible processes we have
um within the existing policies but
we're not afraid to kind of go up to OSD
and say hey guys we might want to
rewrite this thing a little bit look at
what we could do if you rewrite it
here's our proposed language just
sign I noticed in your your bio you talk
about um your team conducting research
and doing experiments to prototype as
well and I was wondering how do you
create that culture where it's okay to
do these experiments
and a little bit about that getting
leader bu on like let's let's not throw
a bunch ofy money let's try it first I
can try it for you for free and you can
figure out how much money you want to
spend on the result I mean some of them
we're looking at different data
integration into selection boards um as
we are doing that we just have the board
members stay on a couple of extra days
do a quick rundown with them and pilot
some of the new look and feel of the
board and see how much it changes their
um their voting from the previous
version and we were looking at things
like inter voter uh voter inter
reliability we're able to explore things
that we haven't been able to explore
before and then we bring the findings
back and again kind of looking at the
quick winds we find the things that are
legit findings bring those back to
senior leaders and go hey guys we tested
this but look at all this other stuff we
found there's more experiments let's go
after this let's go and make you we get
them excited about it we hype it up um
and some of it's like it's not
necessarily world changing right from
the get-go but again kind of the
teaching and communicating piece we were
talking about before we got a Solomon
like hey here's this is just step one
this is just version one if we keep
developing this think about what we
could do I love that that
messaging that's great um Kaitlyn I see
you had a question here in the chat I
was thinking it might be helpful for you
to introduce yourself as
well yeah hi so I'm Caitlyn I'm a
customer success here rep here at posit
and I work with public sector customers
mainly so I've done a lot of work with
army um different mainly Socom Special
Forces
um Operations Command so that's a little
bit about me but my question was um so
you are there instances of not having
enough data um Soldier data that you
know um that is and how currently is HRC
collecting that data um so I'm sorry go
ahead I want to cut you off add and just
to continue on like how how does your
team handle when there's not enough
data so we have a ton of data doesn't
necessarily mean it's the right data um
and as we're going through these models
that's that was actually what kicked off
our Assessment program it's like I don't
have enough in people's files to be able
to say what their what their talent
attributes are and so we go over to our
research entities at the Army Research
Institute Army research labs and say hey
you guys got any kind of existing
studies that we can peel a couple things
off of and take a look at and maybe
experiment and go collect some more data
with um with you guys on this and we've
had a really good partnership with them
it it's also allowed them to kind of
modernize how they're approaching
research because they've got these
things that they can peel off and show
quick wins from their findings rather
than it's like this fiveyear study that
all the leadership is going to change
out before it's done and Leadership
generally um you know they generally
kind of treat that with distrust Chris I
saw something you had posted on LinkedIn
I think it was maybe like a few days ago
about like the importance of being able
to take time off and to be fully off
during that time and I saw you were
asking some advice to other people uh
from your LinkedIn Network too and was
just wondering like what your thoughts
are on that and and what you're you're
learning from your own network too well
that that's kind of the fun part about
this network I love throwing questions
out there and just saying hey guys I'm
human I don't I do a lot of things right
I've been put in a position because you
know you can wave your awesome flag all
day but it's also like you I I screw up
a lot of things I am horrible Tak time
off you know I am I will compulsively go
and check things if not you know I've
got M Mike Carol who's our lead for
procurement but he's also my
accountability but buddy there he's just
like I see you I see you on teams get
off go home um so I love throwing things
like that out to the community uh and
just saying hey you know I'm not the
only person who's dealing with this and
this is a professional Wellness thing I
think all of us can benefit from the
discussion on let me throw it out there
you guys tell me what works for you and
a lot of it kind of came back that same
thing it's like we need that time to do
an an active or inactive recharge you
know sometimes it's like doing yoga or
cross training when you've been trying
to um ramp up for a race you know you
got to do something but make it
something that's not work so you know
trying to figure out those good
substitutions or those complimentary
activities you know we talked earlier
about you know was one of my favorite
things to do not at work I love hiking
love cooking love going to the beach and
I think we've got to let ourselves know
that not only is it okay to have hobbies
not everything has to be work and hustle
but those things actually complement
your ability to refresh recharge and do
your job um so I think it's hugely
important and always trying to figure
out ways to get better at
it I love that idea of how having an
accountability buddy too and like when
we see our our friends at work are on
slack or on teams or whatever when
they're supposed to be off just saying
hey what are you doing here don't
message
me yeah
y my boss is really good at that um
General Drew he'll see me on teams he
goes why are you on teams go be with
your family go away so conversely I'm
just like you better be TDY boss because
otherwise why are you calling me right
um Mike I see you had a question in the
chat a bit earlier want to jump in
here no not really because now my focus
is on this paid time off and question so
I think we should carry on with that
thread rather than J
well okay anybody else have thoughts to
share on that it looks see a lot popping
up in the chat resources yeah okay so so
since you called me out Rachel I'll jump
so this is a personal experience and and
you know I I agree wholeheartedly that
time off should be time away from work
um but um the the kind of personal
anecdote is how many times do I see a
quick question hey I've got a quick
question on teams and I'm like oh yeah I
can answer that and it'll only take a
couple of minutes and and I'll just help
this because that'll unblock that person
right so you just fire off a quick oh
this is where you find that thing right
um but the other thing is that if you
don't do that they don't sit there
blocked for the 24 48 72 week long that
you're out the office they find the
solution
themselves you know so it's almost like
well yes I've been very helpful and I've
answered this question quickly but
actually I've taken my brain from doing
the thing that I was doing to answering
a work question and then I've got to
come back to the the kind of you know
out of office
brain it's hard I think there's a well
there's a big part to that too where
it's like a little bit of un of parking
that um the wanting to be helpful but
also the you know there are lots of
people who could do this there are lot
of people could answer this question or
there are lots of people like on my team
I've got a team of amazing awesome
people who can handle almost like
99.9% of the things out there it's like
there's a little bit of guilt like am I
dumping my work off on somebody else for
this time I'm taking off but at the same
time it's just like you know I need I
need to give them the same um the same
respect when they go on leave and know
they're not dumping off their work I'm
helping them carry stuff or at least
kind of put it in a holding pattern
until they get back I've noticed with
taking time off I I can't use that time
to read work books either because then I
like will be on the beach thinking about
like oh I should work on this project or
oh here's an idea I want to go write it
down um but Jonathan I see you had some
thoughts about this in the chat too you
want to jump in or you don't have to you
can keep it in the chat too okay hi uh
yeah I I just I'm I'm uh an a strong
advocate of of people being away when
they're away and um something that I've
noticed people will use your your email
inbox as kind of a placeholder for
things that they want you to address
when you come back so you come back to
an inbox of you know 350 emails you know
a mixed bag of things that you need
things that you don't need to see you
know things that you're copied on just
for an FYI so I put in my out of office
explicitly that I'm not responding to
anything that's sent while I'm on PTO um
and that if people want me to address
something uh to just delay send it until
I get
back yeah delay send is a awesome
function that's a great idea I hadn't I
hadn't thought of that before I've seen
some people's out of office say
something about like adding urgent to
the subject line so they know like which
emails they need to get to
First yeah but delaying sounds better
let's see any other thoughts on this
topic before we we shift
gears Seth I see you had some thoughts
on this yeah that just got brought up
exact like five seconds after I wrote
that good to know that someone else
likes that
too great well keep keep sharing the
resources and ideas there in the chat
too um when when we get to the last 10
minutes here I want to remind people if
there were questions earlier that we may
be missed in the chat or like a mid
conversation feel free to raise your
hand here on Zoom or maybe even just
like copy and paste those questions over
just so we see them again there too um
but K Rock and rolling yeah we always
have a a big party there in the
chat Kaitlyn I think you had another
question a little bit earlier yeah I
just wanted to ask are there any like
impacts that the Army has changed due to
the work with this new team that you
have or maybe people analytics that team
that we see in the Army today that are
directly from the the work that you were
doing I think the biggest one is um just
getting rid of the additional selection
boards I mean we've taken those and
that's about you know up to eight weeks
of time where we have a bunch of Goos
sitting in a room it's just like okay
well just they're going into an
assessment based on this invitation
that's going to get the in-depth detail
and they're going to go into interviews
they're going to go into all these
things the the file scrub the automatic
kind of scoring of these things that um
spend all this time on they don't need
to do that we can automate that and we
did we automate it we validate it with
the branches just to make sure it makes
sense we get that human back in the loop
but that's going to free up a ton of
time but it's also uncovered a lot of
things that we need to do with
Performance Management um otherwise I
mean just kind of the introduction of
the the two-way Market that HRC is uning
using to preference assignments we've
we're about to U pilot a randomized
control trial for retention incentives
using the retention prediction model
that we have as kind of an OP prior
statistical indicator whether or not
someone is likely to at trit and then if
they take one of these incentives and
sign an additional duty service
obligation we know it's like okay that's
a win we can get a statistical lift
prediction from these pilots on How
likely these different incentives are to
keep people so I think once we get that
rolled out it's going to have a lot of
impact but we're at the point where it's
we've got the model built we've got the
retention incentives kind of picked um
now it's time to do the experiment great
that sounds that's awesome I'm really
looking forward to seeing all of these
changes happen for the I also actually
for those on the call today um I work
part-time for the Texas Army National
Guard so I definitely have like a
personal side interest in in all the
work that Chris is doing so thank
you oh thank you Chris I I thought it
might be interesting to to learn a
little bit more about your own personal
Journey too and and getting into this
role
of leading the HRC 2030 vision and I was
wondering like was was there a specific
moment or something that kind of LED you
to wanting to lead this this initiative
it was a it was an interesting ramp up
um because undergrad my undergrad was in
operations research I commissioned as an
engineer so I really didn't touch
anything until I went back to grad
school um I went back to grad school and
studied complexity science so I was
doing you know rare event simulation
probabilistic design stuff that doesn't
really come into the people Enterprise
went and taught that at West Point for a
while and then my first job as an
operations research and systems analyst
was working theater security cooperation
and building partner capacity kind of
counterterrorism stuff for Indo paycom
then my Branch pulled a fast one on me
and said we're gonna send you to the
Army G1 like what you send me to G1 for
I don't know anything about HR I don't
not I'm not a personalist okay well I
guess I better figure this out and that
kind of was the best thing that could
have happened to me because I was the
Napoleon's Corporal sitting there in the
corner going why do you do this what is
it this doesn't make sense why is this
thing here why are we using Excel
spreadsheets when we've got an
environment where you can house all this
oh because it doesn't have the data in
it how do I get the data put in it and
it just you know this is kind of the
culmination of eight years of curiosity
in building things and asking questions
and trying to get things simulated in
big problems in a space that wasn't
really heavy in the data sphere being
answered by data and now we've got
secretary's focus on it we have a lot of
different focuses coming in that are
leading us to be more data driven and
when the opportunity came up to not just
keep working on because I started people
analytics and you know it's like all
right we got I didn't start it
completely from scratch we took it the
human capital Big Data program and
rolled it up under an existing office
that was actually going to do um make
use and figure out how to build some
serious models out of some of this data
we were using
I did kind of the same thing when I was
at talent management I built a little
startup within there that was turning
out all these data products and it to me
this was kind of the opportunity to do
the same thing within HRC is to you know
sell my other startup to corporate and
I'm gonna go over and do this other
little startup I love like just thinking
of you asking all those questions there
like why are we doing it this way and
and it's making me think of a question I
love to ask people is is there a piece
of career advice that you've either
given or or receive that you'd like to
share with us it it's a tricky one to
give especially in the Army where you're
like your first five to eight years it's
all about you know Conformity and
compliance and after that all of a
sudden they kind of expect you to flip a
switch and go okay now you're in charge
of things be creative and there are a
lot of people who just kind of get
gummed up in the works they don't know
how to do it um I think I tell people to
find you know we're talking about the
hobbies and the other things that um we
want do to exercise our Creative Energy
kind of those opposite IT muscle mental
muscles and I just tell people to you
know it's going to sound silly but you
know exercise your creative Pursuits
find a way to exercise that Creative
Energy so that you know you can keep the
brain the brain flexible um especially
if you want to go into spaces like this
where it's not charted it's very
ambiguous there's not a whole lot of I
mean the last three jobs I had didn't
exist they were created and I got stuck
in them and there's no book there's no
notes there's no anything about how to
do this particular job I mean so I had
to go out you know like we were talking
about before if you're not there to
answer a question the person's going to
go find the answers so I'm G to go out
and talk to other HR professionals and
see how they're doing this I'm going to
go talk to other data science
professionals to see how they're doing
this and put together you know kind of a
hodg Podge answer to try out and
experiment and I mean this is just kind
of a great place for it and I saw it pop
up in the in the comments data science
is a great place to be here ious um if I
were in my home office I have a poster
of Sherlock Holmes from the movie Up
behind because he's always going data
data data you know I need data I need to
solve problems I want to go and you know
dig into this I want to solve a case I'm
gonna be a data detective
so it just gets you excited I mean find
a way to exercise those creative
Pursuits because they're fun and you'll
find I think you'll use those to find
that kind of creative fun in your work
also I love that thank you Chris and I I
can like hear the excitement from you as
you're explaining that too I love it I
love my job I won't
lie one other I know we have a few
minutes here but one other question that
was asked anonymously was how do you
stay updated with the latest and
greatest Tech that you can use and
enable your team
with conversations like this getting out
to you know I I've made the argument
that the Army because we pulled back on
conferences for a while it's like we
need to go to professional conferences
we need to go to Industry conferences we
need to go talk to people who are doing
this work we need to go back to school
we need to go do training with industry
um you know we need to be able to go and
find the people who are leading the edge
and create those networks so you know
when we do have a problem and we're like
okay what is what is industry do we know
who's leading in this Edge what kind of
Technology could we take or what do we
need to develop and how do we do it that
you've got a phone of friend available
and I won't say I'm always the most upto
dat and don't I have a little bit of a
pass from Army just because a lot of our
stuff is legacy and it doesn't
necessarily take the most Cutting Edge
thing to solve those problems but I do
like knowing what's going on where the
field is going absolutely we keep a a a
running list of books and
recommendations from data science
hangout leaders and everybody here well
when I say we Libby is actually the one
doing it so do you have any
recommendations for books or things
you're reading now we should check out
I've got a whole laundry list
um uh it's probably been brought up a
few times but if you're doing any kind
of transformation and modernization the
Unicorn project is a mustre um I'm
reading um further faster and far less
drama By Janice Frasier right now it's
about change management and transforming
organizations that's another good one
and I got recommended um Jeff Bear's um
I think that's who it's by uh it's
called hug your haters and it's about
customer experience and customer service
but the reason I love it is it teaches
you to seek out actively seek out
criticism and critics and find the
people who are just making noise but
also find the ones who have a legitimate
complaint and figure out how you can
solve their problems for them so that's
I love that thank you for reminding me
of that book I heard of it like a few
months ago and completely forgot I need
to go add that to the list too well I
see lots of good detective books popping
up in the chat too so yeah it seems like
there's a lot of us here who wanted to
be detectives or Sherlock Holmes Nancy J
at some point in our
life so it has probably
finding cles yeah absolutely well thank
you so much Chris for joining us today
it's been a pleasure hearing from you
and learning from your experience thank
you for all that you do thank you so
much for letting me join this is awesome
have a great rest of the day everybody
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you all next week cheers bye
everybody